all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one is
david based on the numbers we're seeing
about loyalty to donald trump and people
willing to leave the republican party if
he starts a new party
is it fair to say that donald trump's
voters are more loyal to him
than obama and biden's voters are loyal
to them
i think that there's a complexity to
this question because
what we mean by loyalty may not be the
same thing
if what we mean by loyalty we mean
lack of willingness to criticize them in
other words
you're loyal in that you'll never
criticize anything they do
i think that yes donald trump's
followers
are more loyal to him you see many on
the left
who vote for it voted for biden voted
for obama
voted for obama for reelection and yet
had many criticisms
of them and some might say that that
means they're less loyal
i don't know i'm not so sure about that
i i think that
one of the things that does that is
unique to the trump voter
is that because many of them either were
sort of like disaffected republicans who
already had
some disdain for the republican party or
were brought into politics by trump
and if trump had been a democrat they
would have become democrats
trump ran as a republican so they're you
know putatively ostensibly republicans
they don't really care about the
republican party
and when you think about all of these
folks who
joined politics essentially to follow
donald trump they liked the dog
whistling
on the xenophobic sort of racist stuff
they don't really care about abortion
like you know trump made up this thing
about how he used to be pro-choice now
he's pro-life because he met a kid he
liked or something like that
uh at 68 and then he became pro-life and
so that
appealed to some of the evangelicals
most historical republicans went with
trump because they weren't going to go
for hillary but
the people that trump brought in they
don't really care about most of the
stuff that a lot of republicans care
about they'll go with it if trump wants
it but
they're not really about the debt
they're not really about abortion
they're not really about religious
liberty
they liked the sort of vibe of trump and
the dog whistling
that came with it trump came in and he
said you know george w bush was wrong on
the war and
mitt romney sucks and i you know john
mccain i prefer
war heroes who don't get captured and
obama might not even be american and
the mexican rapist and all this
different stuff and that was really what
they were
motivated by and so it's less to me
that they are super loyal to trump it's
that they don't really care about
anything else that's going on in the
political world they never really cared
about anything
other than trump's words even trump's
actions they don't really care about
remember
about seven eight months into trump's
presidency i got a call from some guy in
california i think it was
who said you know trump's just the best
everything he's done his best
and i said well what has he actually
done so far and he didn't actually list
anything
and i said well what motivated you to
vote for trump what promises did you
like and he said building the wall
i said okay so if there's no wall across
the entire border in november of 2020
you're not voting for trump and he said
no i'm probably still voting for trump
they don't really care about issues they
they care about trump
because of the things he says and how he
says them and in that way
it's a debate whether you call it
loyalty
or simply they don't care enough about
anything else
to consider abandoning donald trump i
think it's the latter
you tell me whether the term loyalty
does or doesn't apply
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home
i absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position your back pain issues
you might have
and their tool matched me with a
mattress
that is perfect for me it's cool enough
at night
it's the right firmness i generally just
do
way better sleeping these days because
of the mattress
helix was awarded number one best
overall mattress for the last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to
200 off your order and you'll get two
super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video